henry cavill may be making a return to a
high-profile franchise no not that one
the rumor monger is that we got this
covered up back with a new report that's
too good to believe claiming that henry
cavill who portrayed the villainous CIA
turncoat august Walker in Mission
Impossible fallouts may return for the
next installments you may be wondering
how this is possible
fans will remember that drawing fallouts
climax Ethan Hunt was forced to chase
down Walker in a commandeered helicopter
in order to prevent the latter from
putting into motion a plan to
contaminate a massive portion of the
world's water supply with stolen nuclear
weapons after a stunningly shot cruise
endangered aerial chase hunt forces
Walker to crash-land by well just
straight-up crashing into him that
engages a villain and fisticuffs on a
treacherous snowy mountain side of
course the ever resourceful Hans finds
an exceedingly cinematic way to dispatch
his nemesis dropping one of the
helicopters winch hooks on him and
crushing him to death the detonators are
secured the world's water supply is safe
and as for Walker well he's just super
dead if you're thinking it seems like
fallouts ending will preclude a return
to the role of Walker by cavil well
we're right there with you
so how would it happen a dream sequence
perhaps a flashback
maybe the as of yet entitled Mission
Impossible 7 will be a prequel or
perhaps Auguste Walker was actually the
nefarious alter-ego of Superman a guy
whom he bears a suspicious resemblance
to and he was therefore able to simply
shake off getting a haften winch hook
dropped on him in our humble opinion the
answer is none of the above because
we're pretty sure that this rumor is
baloney for a couple of simple reasons
first couples character is again dead as
a doornail at the conclusion of fallouts
seconds the mysterious inside sources
are literally the only ones reporting
this and those sources sources that may
well just be reddit posts and Twitter
are often terribly embarrassing ly wrong
sorry but it's true people actually fall
also there's a fact that when it comes
to Mission Impossible 7 & 8 which we'll
shoot back to back very few details have
been made public we suppose it's
possible that our hits a miss generally
a reliable source could look his way
into accurate information that exactly
zero of putable media outlets have yet
caught up with off but we have any
reason to believe it no not really no
we're gonna go ahead and peg this rumor
as completely unfounded and probably
total bunk first and foremost we're up
the opinion that Haley Atwell improves
anything she is involved with and the
next two Mission Impossible movies will
have precisely one more Hayley Atwell
than any of the previous films and the
franchise have had star of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the late great
series agent Carter as well as one of
the more talented actresses working
today and she's already proven that she
totally has what it takes to be an
action star
seconds the ageless apparently
indestructible Cruise is returning as
hunts as is Rebecca Ferguson who has
shined in the last three Mission
Impossible pictures as Ilsa forced the
former British intelligence agent and
operative for the criminal organization
known as The Syndicate who is now firmly
on the side of hunt and the IMF her
chemistry with Cruise has only grown
more potent during a tenure in the
franchise anti-returned is most welcome
finally writer director Christopher
McQuarrie will be back to fill both
roles of Mission Impossible 7 and dates
and this is a guy who knows how to write
for and direct cruise perhaps better
than anyone in Hollywood he wrote and
helmed 2012 Jack Reacher turned in an
amazing screenplay for the time twisting
sci-fi edge of tomorrow and has
masterminded the previous two Mission
Impossible movies which were among the
series best yes he also wrote the mummy
the film that both launched and sealed
the doom of universals dark universe
franchise but we can't forgive him for
that Mission Impossible has improbably
proven to be one of the best action
franchises of all time starting off
strong and seeming to only get better as
it keeps trucking along personally we
can't wait for the seventh and eighth
installments to hit screens and when
they do we're pretty sure it'll be
without cover cruise though seems to
want to keep making these movies until
he's a Z and we have a feeling he
probably well provided one of them
doesn't finally do am in Mission
Impossible 7 is slated for release on
July 23rd 2021
Mission Impossible AIDS will follow on
August 5th 2020 to check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bowel so you don't miss a single one
[Music]